according to a new poll 48 of americans
do not believe that joe biden is
mentally sound enough to effectively
serve as president which raises a very
important question
what are 52 percent of americans
thinking are they not paying any
attention are they blind are they deaf
are they just plain stupid
well the joke's on us because
even though half the country believes
that joe biden is basically a vegetable
he and his associates will continue to
run the show there's not nothing that we
can do about it there actually are some
key republicans who are doing the right
things but time is running out i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knoll
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from zachary who
said he must have known what i was going
to talk about today because he wrote i'm
not sure why everyone is taking orders
from a person who is just above
vegetable status yes i think a lot of
people are thinking that i actually did
not
even see that comment by the time i
wrote my show but a lot of people are
thinking about half the country is
thinking it and i think there is an
answer to that by the way which is that
biden and his associates and the broader
liberal regime
is just convincing everyone that their
rule is inevitable that there's no
choice that even if a vegetable is at
the top of the heap
their
rule their priorities are what is going
to happen you know
it just it's enough to give you a
headache it's enough to make you want
some relief which is why i would check
out relief band if you regularly suffer
from car sickness or nausea you have got
to check out relief band relief band is
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
that's associated with
motion sickness anxiety uh chemotherapy
morning sickness hangovers i mean a
whole variety
it's an amazing product the way that it
works because i was a little skeptical
of it it stimulates a nerve in your
wrist that travels to the part of the
brain that controls nausea and then it
blocks the signal that your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you to
feel sick so it's 100 drug-free it's
non-drowsy it's all-natural long-lasting
relief with zero side effects you may
have tried some cheap imitator in the
past you know you pick up something for
10 or 15 bucks at the drugstore it
doesn't work this is not that this is
number one fda cleared clinically proven
to work as the world opens back up do
not let fear of nausea keep you on the
sidelines right now relief band has an
exclusive offer just for michael knowles
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
use promo code knowledge you will get 20
off you will also get free shipping you
will also get a 30 day money back
guarantee that is
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d dot com promo code
knows for 20 off plus free
shipping so this poll this is a fox news
poll but
i have no reason to think that it's not
a reliable poll
uh 49 of americans think that biden has
the mental soundness to serve 48
say he does not and i don't know i guess
three percent of americans were out
making a sandwich or something they
weren't paying attention to this this is
really bad news for biden not just
because half the country thinks he's a
vegetable but because the numbers are
getting worse for him so they were asked
this question
uh
weeks before
and 49 again said yes he's fit to serve
but 40 45 only 45 percent said no he's
not mentally fit enough to serve now
that number has jumped up to 48 number
very likely will go higher
the way that the liberal establishment
is
working around joe biden's obvious
decline and unfitness
is not that they're defending biden
you'll notice they're not really
defending biden as much anymore not that
they're promoting kamala harris she's
extremely unlikable so they're not
they're not trying that either what they
are doing is they are trying to present
the biden rule and biden is just a
stand-in for the broader liberal rule as
inevitable
so this is from the ap this is the
associated press
an ap reporter john lemaire tweets out
quote the pentagon admitted that its
errant drone strike or admitted its
aaron dronestrike the one that killed 10
people including seven kids coveted
boosters did not get full approval
france recalled its ambassador the
punishing headlines all within an hour
underscored the perils for a president
from uncontrollable events that can
define a term
uncontrollable events
uh these
these all seem very controllable to me
the the drone strike that did not
kill a terrorist but instead killed an
aid worker and two adult members of his
family and seven kids
was not uncontrollable it didn't just
fall out of the sky on a meteor or a
meteorite it someone pushed the button
and someone gave the order and someone
authorized the military to give this
order that was controllable covid
boosters did not get full approval this
also was controllable the messaging
confusion on coronavirus was extremely
controllable going all the way back to
the masks don't work yes the masks work
we're not going to get a vaccine we did
get a vaccine the vaccine's very
effective but actually the vaccine's not
effective enough so you need a booster
the the vaccine is extremely safe but
actually the vaccine is not safe enough
to get approval for the booster all of
that was controllable if you didn't lie
and mislead people and get out ahead of
your story and then france were calling
its ambassador france recalled its
ambassador because the united states
struck a deal with the united kingdom
and australia and excluded france from
the deal to counter the rise of china if
we had just involved france in that
decision or made some way to mitigate
the fallout when we didn't include
france in that decision that would have
been controllable too
but the liberal regime is
incompetent sometimes and malicious at
other times and now they're getting
pushback for that and now they're trying
to pretend that it's it's uncontrollable
it is very controllable by the way worth
pointing out that's from the associated
press when you look at those ridiculous
charts of the reliable news sites and
these are not reliable down at the
bottom of the pyramid but the ones at
the top are much more reliable ap is at
the very tippy top
and the ap
is shilling for the regime
now getting to the the very first thing
they point out here the pentagon's drone
strike
joe biden he doesn't come out and
address any of this he probably can't
but his spokesman does jen saki comes
out and in true biden fashion
makes the drone strike that killed 10
people including seven kids entirely
about him
following up on the drum strike
last week that the pentagon now emits
was a tragic mistake
what was the president's response when
he learned about that
well the president was briefed
on friday morning
about the
the
report that was going to be released and
put out i would say first the
president's view and all of our view is
that the loss of any civilian life is a
tragedy uh as was as was made clear in
the comments by the secretary of defense
uh by uh general mckenzie this was done
in error
and clearly
the investigation that will continue is
something the president broadly supports
so as a human being
as a president as somebody who has
overseen loss in a variety of scenarios
both as a leader and personally it is
his reaction is it's a tragedy and every
loss is a tragedy and he supports the
efforts to the effort to move this
forward as quickly as possible and to
have a thorough investigation
how dare you
how dare you ask joe biden why he droned
that family with seven kids
how dare he
he has experienced loss too
don't
maybe we could have a little
sympathy or a little empathy here okay
not for the family that was zapped out
of this from the sky but
but for joe biden because he's
experienced laws he does this a lot and
the thing is joe biden actually has
experienced loss right his
wife was killed in a car crash and his
son died of cancer and it's
the man has actually had a difficult
life and
you know one would have a great deal of
sympathy for him
except that he trots this out all the
time he exploits these deaths and losses
for political
gain
and it's it's unseemly maybe he's doing
it out of a place of genuine brokenness
and and sorrow and it could be
maybe he's doing this for political
effect he did because
the reason i think it's the latter is
because his wife was killed by a driver
the driver you know there were a lot of
tests done there was an investigation
the driver just had an accident it's not
like he was drunk it's not like he was
on drugs it was just a tragic accident
and joe biden acknowledged this and it
really haunted the guy his whole life
then the minute the guy died joe biden
started saying out of nowhere that he
was drunk started smearing him as drunk
on the campaign trail it was just a
vicious lie about the guy really hurt
his family it was it was obviously not
true so i i think it was the latter
and this is typical
of
of joe biden so i i don't he's
it just shows you the desperation on his
part for any sort of sympathy whatsoever
because he's in a really bad spot
politically but the regime broadly is
not in a bad spot they are still pretty
firmly entrenched
in power
now the question is in 2024 who replaces
joe biden if the republicans do win who
is the president going to be there is a
new poll just came out
nearly 58 percent of republicans
nearly six and 10
would nominate donald trump again trump
is absolutely
dominating the republican presidential
field
number two this was a little surprising
to me mike pence mike pence comes in
second with 13
ron desantis comes in third with only
nine percent we're talking about ron
desantis as though he's the republican
nominee he's only got nine percent
support
uh rubio and nikki haley both have about
three percent
now the question shifts
when you take trump out of the field
so if trump is not in the field the
numbers are very different
pence comes in on top with 32 support
ron desantis with 20 support
ted cruz with 14 support the rest i
think are
yeah a little bit too low to care about
right now so
what does this mean it means one
donald trump is still considered to be
the strongest
republican
he's the one who is punching back
against not just the liberal
establishment but his own establishment
which is a pretty amazing thing
that the republicans still support him
six out of 10 republicans still support
him
but i think it also shows you that the
people who are ready to just crown ron
desantis right now desantis is doing a
great job i don't mean to
speak ill of what he's doing in florida
but the people who are willing to crown
him i think are are getting ahead of
themselves there's still a long way to
go one last poll before we get to why
the polls don't mean anything at all
right now in virginia there's a race
that seemed competitive
it used to seem competitive now it seems
less competitive this is a terry
mcauliffe the democrat versus glenn
yunken there was a poll done by the l
douglas wilder school of government
public affairs at virginia commonwealth
university 43 of likely voters are
supporting mcauliffe
that's nine points higher than the 34
who support yunkan this means that
mcauliffe is increasing his lead over
yunkan i pointed this out after the
debate where the republican glenn
younkin came out he was he was asked
about the texas abortion law and he
criticized the texas abortion law and he
tried to pretend that he was going to be
a more moderate squishy type of guy i
said that was a bad answer because you
didn't pick up any lib votes but you
irritated a lot of conservatives who may
not not be motivated to vote for you now
especially in a state that people
considered democrat
that would seem to be playing out right
now do not squish squishing is a bad
idea but the thing is despite all of
these polls
that's only one aspect of the political
problem for republicans the broader one
is that the liberal establishment has
tightened its grip on power and very
likely will not
will not let us win in the future
when you want to protect yourself
against all these sorts of things and
against burglars and against in-laws i
would recommend you check out ring
sometimes i go on the road sometimes i
visit different colleges and speak at
different places like i'm doing right
now and when i am on the road i can have
peace of mind because of ring alarm the
ring alarm security system
just gives you so much ease you all know
about the
video doorbells where you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door whether
it's the delivery guy or the pizza guy
or your mother-in-law and you can
calibrate your response accordingly all
right but you can also keep an eye on
every corner of your home
outdoors indoors and you can control
that all from a very simple app it's
great it just makes me feel good to know
that sweet little elisa and cute little
baby june are safe whether i'm in the
house whether i am outside of the house
makes a great housewarming gift because
it's top tier technology and not very
expensive so you get good credit for a
good gift you won't have to spend a lot
protect your home anytime from anywhere
with ring alarm
go to ring.com knowles for a special
offer on a ring alarm security kit today
build the system that's right for your
home have it up and running in minutes
that is ring.com
knowles ring.com
knowles
we all talk about the horse race and
well this candidate said this and this
candidate did this and well this will
appeal to voters and this will appeal to
the suburban women and this will and you
you're kind of missing the broader point
here on how our elections are conducted
which is that there are other forces at
play beyond public opinion
you saw this with some of the election
rules that were passed or just
implemented without being legal in 2020
the libs putting their thumb on the
scales of the election
saying oh okay yeah well you can
campaign all you want but we're going to
institute widespread mail and ballots
without any voter id
we're going to institute motor voter
laws we're going to institute ballot
harvesting we're going to
continue counting the votes for days and
days and weeks and weeks why are we
doing that i don't know we're going
we're going to do this that and the
other thing to tilt the election in our
favor and even that the the election the
specific election frog stuff even that
is just one aspect there's another
aspect which is that the people who
control the flow of information the
people who control the public square
are not going to allow republicans
too much freedom to make their case
there's a candidate right now for
governor of michigan garrett soldano
he's a primary candidate to be the next
governor he has been permanently
blacklisted
from youtube
youtube owned by google this is
according to reports
so this guy's running for governor of
michigan but he can't present his
message on the largest video platform in
the world
he can't run ads on the largest video
platform in the world owned by the most
powerful company basically ever in the
history of the world that has more
information on you and can not only
predict your behavior but impel your
behavior in a way that no other company
has ever been able to do a company that
has extremely close ties to the federal
government that has taken money from the
federal government that gives
information to the federal government
that shares a lot of employees with the
federal government
they are now saying no that republican
nope
poof
and he's gone
google did this
a little while ago
to rand paul
rand paul sitting united states senator
youtube censored a video of him speaking
on the floor of the senate
we think that our government is ruled by
the executive in the white house and the
judges at the supreme court and the
house members in the lower chamber and
the senators in the upper chamber of the
legislature
and that's just not true
if that were true
that would be the place with the
greatest political breadth the greatest
freedom of speech and freedom of
whatever
but it's not
because
then there's google and google can
decide if it likes what people are
saying on the floor of the senate it
will permit that to be broadcast into
the public square
and if it doesn't you know if it's rand
paul saying something then they're just
going to disappear it and you're not
going to see it and that's that
poof see ya in both of these cases by
the way it's because these gentlemen
said things that contradicted the
liberal regime's covid policies the
kovid policies of course are now not
just one aspect of their broader agenda
it is the agenda the covid lockdowns are
everything it the co the covid
regulations
now
we'll regulate the way that we
travel the way we go to school the way
we go to work the way we buy things the
way we speak the way we dress the way we
have our medical care the way we relate
our medical information
it touches everything touches everything
in the whole country
and so if a republican senator or a
governor candidate jubinatorial
candidate
in any way criticize the way that the
liberal regime is governing everything
well the regime might just say poof
you're gone
this is uh something that the the left
has been working on for a long time this
is a strategy that the left has been
honing and perfecting for the better
part of a hundred years
through the
certainly the progressivism of woodrow
wilson that it gets implemented by fdr
but i think you see it really start to
hit its stride with global warming
global warming
has it has all of the same
characteristics that we're seeing with
the covid regulations the time is
running out we have to suspend the
normal way our society runs you have to
give us a ton more power you have to let
us regulate every aspect of your life
you we it's urgent you'll die if we
don't it's for public health if you
question us you're a murderer it's all
it's all the same stuff they've been
more effective with kovid because me
people are more afraid of germs than
they are of the sun monster but it's the
exact same strategy and so joe biden now
speaking at the united nations doesn't
want to put all of his eggs in the covid
basket he also wants to put some of them
in the sun monster basket
this year has also brought widespread
death and devastation
from the borderless climate crisis
the extreme weather events
that we have seen in every part of the
world and you all know it and feel it
represent what the secretary general has
rightly called
code red for humanity
and the scientists and experts are
telling us
that we're fast approaching
a point of no return in a literal sense
to keep within our reach
the vital goal of limiting global
warming to 1.5 degrees celsius every
nation
needs to bring their highest possible
ambitions to the table
when we meet in glasgow for cop 26.
the point of no return in the literal
sense not the figurative sense in the
literal sense of course he is describing
the figurative sense he doesn't mean
that we're getting it's not we're not
getting to some geographic location
where you can't turn around anymore
but
again joe biden not not a whole lot
going on between the ears
my question is
when
do we get to that point
when do we get to the point of no return
that's the fear
it's a code red
we're
so we're now so close to a point where
any of our efforts to mitigate global
warming will do nothing there'll be to
no avail if we get to this point of no
return so we've got to do everything now
when's the point
tell me when give me a date for the
point
because then once we get to that point i
don't want to hear it anymore i don't
want to hear about how we have to do
this and we have to you just told me
it's the point of no return
so let's live it up buddy
now he's not going to give you a date
and if he does give you a date he's
going to downplay that date and
everyone's going to forget about that
date because they've given us that date
before they've been doing this for
decades 1989 noel brown environmentalist
who was associated with the united
nations
said that entire nations could be wiped
off the face of the earth by rising sea
levels if global warming is not reversed
by the year 2000. okay so
at least that's a specific time right he
says in 1989 if in 11 years we have not
reversed global warming entire nations
are going to be wiped off the earth
the year 2000 came i guess we didn't
reverse global warming we're still
talking about it so okay it's over it's
over we've reached the point of no
return so shut up about it
but they don't shut up about it the year
2000 david viner british climate
scientist says
children just aren't going to know what
snow is
we're really going to get caught out
snow will probably cause chaos in 20
years times people aren't going to know
what it is
here's just one headline from uh from
2018
you know 18 years in london has been hit
by a wall of snow and a huge blizzard as
the uk is rocked by bone chilling
temperatures ice and wintry weather from
the beast from the east it goes on so
people i think children still know what
snow is
20 years on
it's all it's all still the same the
predictions were completely wrong we
didn't reach any point of no return 2008
the forum for the future says refugees
are expected to move to antarctica
because of the rising temperatures that
will see the population of the continent
increase to 3.5 million people by 2040.
i think
uh in many parts of antarctica the
temperature is something like negative
70 degrees fahrenheit
and then the nicest the most temperate
parts of antarctica it's about 14
degrees fahrenheit i don't think anyone
is is moving there building building
their home to to set up their family to
live in antarctica 2009 here we go this
is this is the stuff you hear uk prime
minister gordon brown if we do not reach
a deal at this time let us be in no
doubt once the damage from unchecked
emissions growth is done no
retrospective global agreement in some
future period can undo that choice
so we should never allow ourselves to
lose sight of the catastrophe we face if
present warming trends continue so there
it is 2009 if we don't strike a deal
right now if we don't reverse global
warming right now there is nothing that
we can do in the future to reverse it
and undo it okay well we didn't do it
didn't happen so it's over right so shut
up about it and then 2011 prince charles
is my favorite one prince charles says
that he had calculated that we had just
96 months
left to save the world 96 months is
eight years this was in 2011 that would
bring us to 2019 that when the world was
over the world ended in 2019 nothing to
do
anymore that was two years ago where are
we
are we are we in antarctica no we're not
well we're still just
we're still just all throughout the
world and it's all just fine
and they think we're stupid and we are
stupid because we don't pay attention to
this
if you do not pay attention if you do
not notice that they keep shifting the
goal posts if you do not see their
transparent fear-mongering for what it
is then you deserve the rule of the
regime that you're currently living
under remember that they would tell us
donald trump his language is dark and
divisive dark and divisive listen to the
way joe biden's talking a cold horrible
death and destruction is coming and it's
but it's not
but it's not no more than it always is
because this is a fallen world
but if we do not
if we do not see this for what it is
we deserve the government that we have
you know
when you want to
preserve your life at least your digital
life i would strongly recommend you
check out lifelock people want your data
they want your information and a lot of
the time they don't want to do very good
stuff with that information they will
try to take your identity payment apps
like venmo cash app and others make
payments really easy
but then if you if you don't pay
attention to your privacy settings
some of them will share your personal
information a recent report found that
payment apps share user data with third
parties such as banks fraud monitoring
services some even share it with
marketing firms it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every
single day we put our information at
risk on the internet in an instant a
cyber criminal could harm what's yours
your finances your credit your good
reputation good thing there is lifelock
which detects a wide range of identity
theft
for instance your social security number
for sale on the dark web you have access
to a dedicated restoration specialist if
you are a victim no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours with lifelock by
norton right now join save up to 25 off
your first year at lifelock.com slash
knowles that is lifelock.com slash
knowles for 25 off also
as the uh
kovidistan government is is now in place
as we are now ruled through the whims of
the public health apparatchiks
who who are trying to control every
aspect of our life including making us
all take that experimental drug through
your employer
maybe you would like to stand with daily
wire as we say no as we say no to the
biden mandate as we say we will not
comply head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply at
checkout for 25 off we will be right
back with a lot more
the question we started the show with is
how are people
following orders from a guy who seems to
be half a vegetable at this point
the answer to that is
because the regime makes it seem
inevitable
and when i say the regime when i say the
ruling class when i say the
establishment i'm talking mostly about
democrats but a little bit about
republicans too there's a wonderful guy
angelo codevilla
who is a claremont scholar he was a a
foreign policy expert he had been a
foreign service officer he had worked in
senate intelligence
is really
one of the
most important minds on the right for
understanding our current political
moment he is someone who
said that we're living in an oligarchy
that we were living in a republic but
now we're living in an oligarchy and
coincidentally
i gave a show yesterday on this very
point and coincidentally or however you
want to see it it's very sadly angelo
cotavillo was killed yesterday was
killed in a car accident
and he was 78 years old but he was still
publishing constantly and he had had a
whole lot more left in him
but but
angelo makes this point you know that
we're we're now living under this sort
of oligarchic regime and in that it's
not that the republicans and democrats
are exactly the same the democrats are
the senior partners okay they're the
ones who formed this regime first by
woodrow wilson and then it was
implemented by franklin roosevelt but
there are republicans who are the junior
partners who want to be part of the
regime who want to be considered
intelligent want to get invited to fancy
parties this is you know the people who
are the court conservatives the the
people whose job it is basically just to
legitimize the liberal regime by
criticizing republicans at crucial
moments
and it's no surprise that
one of the outlets that serves this
purpose it's funded by democrat money
and it is run by disaffected former
republicans who
all they want to do now is suck up to to
the liberal regime it's a great
testament to angelo cotavilla that
yesterday when he died the bulwark
celebrated his death that's that's a
very fine tribute one of the finest
tributes that man could have gotten
the way that they do this democrat
senior partners the republican junior
partners the liberal blob that extends
not just in the public sphere the
government but also in the private
sphere like google and
all the rest of it
is they make their rules seem inevitable
that was always the point that they
understood the science of politics this
was the argument of progressivism and so
they're going to take political power
away from the people they're going to
give it to technocratic experts to to
the scientists who understand the
science of history and the science of
politics and the science of science and
they are going to run our lives for us
so the way that they rule is through a
kind of determinism there's nothing you
can do the tides of history are always
going to move in this one direction
that's why we're on the right side of
history they use all of this language
and they don't just do it on the
microbes and they don't just do it on
the sun monster they do it on economic
matters for instance as well chuck
schumer was just
just defending his party's last ditch
effort to cram in an amnesty for illegal
aliens mass amnesty into their
ridiculous three and a half trillion
dollar budget bill and the senate
parliamentarian said you actually can't
do that so chuck schumer started out his
diatribe by blasting the senate
parliamentarian and he explains why the
flood of illegal aliens into our country
is
necessary and inevitable
we're short of workers from one end of
america to the other one of the reasons
the trump administration dramatically
cut back on immigrants in this country
we need them
we need them in our labor force we need
them to continue american vitality
we need them because they're part of the
american dream
it's estimated in my city by some that
one third of the health care workers at
the height of covid
who risked their lives for us
were immigrants
having
a
a strong
law that helps our immigrants
is vital the american people understand
that fixing our broken immigration
system is a moral imperative and an
economic imperative
immigration reform has been one of the
most important causes of my time in the
senate and i will not stop fighting to
achieve it
it is one of the most important causes
to chuck schumer because
he believes that it will give him a
permanent majority so that's why he's
trying to give mass amnesty to people
who statistically are much more likely
to side with democrats but do you hear
his argument
beyond the typical the health care
workers they're the immigrants are the
greatest people in the whole world and
they never do anything bad and they only
do things that are good and how dare you
not give them amnesty even though the
first act they did in our country was
break our laws some of our most basic
laws
so what chuck schumer does here
is beyond the typical
political sentimental stuff he says this
is inevitable it's predetermined we need
it we need
immigration we we even need illegal
immigration
because
that's the only way to keep our economy
running he's saying look we have a labor
shortage
now why do we have a labor we do kind of
have a labor show we have a labor
shortage in part because democrats are
paying americans to stay home
so we have a largely contrived
constructed intentional labor shortage
but even before covet they were still
making these arguments before coveted
why were they making these arguments
they were making these arguments because
they would say look
we need
the immigrants to come in to do these
jobs because americans are not having
babies right we are not replacing
ourselves in this country the birth
rates are plummeting the only way to
keep our economy going is to flood the
country with immigrants so why are
americans not having babies i'm sure
there are a number of reasons but one of
the reasons is
child care is very expensive and
americans can no longer support a family
on a single income
why is that the case why is it so
expensive to have kids well because
people aren't making the same kinds of
wages that they used to make relative to
the rest of the economy why aren't they
making the same kind of wages they used
to make oh in no small part because
we're flooding the country with
immigrants and when we're not flooding
the country with immigrants or i suppose
in tandem with flooding the country with
immigrants we're outsourcing a lot of
good jobs also to boost up gdp because
we got to boost up gdp even though the
gains are going to go disproportionately
to people who are on the side of the
regime and the deplorable irredeemable
working-class americans are going to get
absolutely hosed in the
in the ensuing
process
do you see the perversity of this
the illegal immigration is inevitable
and necessary
because
of the situation that we ourselves
constructed
but we set up the system to flood the
country with the immigrants it's this
feedback cycle and no one is allowed to
say boo about hey
don't flood the country with a lot of
low low skilled labor that's going to
lower american wages just don't do it
you have a labor shortage bump up wages
how about that
outsource them but we have we have to
flood the country with cheap labor you
know you don't no you don't but the
economists tell me we have to well i
don't care what the economists say but
the experts the experts say that we have
to i don't care what the experts say i
care what we the people say because i
think we still have self-government
don't we
maybe we don't we did have
self-government before we transformed
from a republic
increasingly into an oligarchy but i
think there's still a little glimmer of
hope left and i don't want to hear a
word from i don't want to hear boo from
the experts and you know what i don't
want you outsourcing our jobs to china
either
but michael
michael the experts say that we there's
no way i actually i spoke to a
conservative some years ago said michael
which party do you think is going to
bring the jobs back from china
i said i don't know i mean i guess the
republicans we said wrong answer the
jobs are not coming back they can't come
back there's no way they can come back
it's inevitable it's not inevitable
it's not inevitable
trump who you know was less effective
than we we'd all hoped he would be
he brought some manufacturing jobs back
it's not
it's not inevitable
it's such a it's such a farce it's such
a
such an op to you
in honor of angelo cotaville i'll use
terms from the claremont people today
it's an op it's it's just a political
operation
to
look at what aoc is doing right now
remember aoc wore that dress the other
day
but aoc
was was
showing up to the met gala the fanciest
event of the year and she shows up with
all her fancy friends thirty five
thousand dollars a ticket she wears a
dress that says tax the rich ooh
whoo spicy s she's a radical oh gosh
right except she's not she's a tool of
the plutocratic neo-liberal oligarchy
and she's sort of she's one of their
little gestures on the left and then
they've got their little gestures on the
right like the you know the people whose
magazines they fund
and
and that's it and then there's the
pretend opposition but they continue to
rule so aoc is taking one step further
she is now
she's now created a line of tax the rich
products
she's now selling tax the rich merch on
her website
you can get a sweatshirt for the low low
proletarian price of 58.
you can get a t-shirt for the
really reasonable 27 for a t-shirt
you can get a dad hat i don't know what
that is for 28 bucks
i'm a dad so i probably own some you get
a sticker pack oh stickers are only 10
bucks
a mug for 27
and a tote bag for 27
this is outrageous
it
if we're gonna tax if we're gonna go eat
the rich let's start with
the aoc campaign merch fund
but it's all just
it highlights in particular what a farce
the whole thing is yeah
stick it to the man
yeah tax the rich by giving me 58
dollars for a sweatshirt yeah that'll
show him yeah
yeah look i look when i went to the
fancy party with all my extremely rich
friends masters of the universe
oligarchs yeah i wore a dress
that
had kind of you know it's it was
subversive wasn't it and that's why they
all celebrated me for it and put me in
magazines because of how subversive it
was and it's so subversive i'm gonna
sell it for 58 bucks
is there a way to fight back i don't
want to just leave us on this really
down negative note because i because i'm
not a determinist either i think that
there actually is still a way to fight
back though like joe biden with the sun
monster i do think time is running out
i don't i don't think there's a point of
no return but i think there's a point at
which we might have to suffer through a
thousand years of darkness before we can
you know
start to fight back again i don't think
we're there yet either so how do we
fight back ron desantis in florida is
actually showing away ron desantis is
showing away
by playing
politics the way that politics actually
exists not the way that we pretend it
exists in civics class but the way it
actually exists
he's doing it through one of his
appointments through a public health
appointment through the new surgeon
general of florida
i'm pleased to be able to
be with you all today to announce that
dr joseph lattipo will be surgeon
general for the state of florida
dr lattipo comes with us by way of the
david geffen school of medicine at ucla
he graduated from wake forest and
received his medical degree from harvard
medical school and his phd in health
policy from harvard graduate school of
arts and sciences and his medical board
certifications include internal medicine
american board of internal medicine in
2011. he comes to florida with really a
superb background
bringing superb intellect but also i
think will bring great leadership
okay so
this is a little strange for ron
desantis to be going through this litany
of all the credentials all of the
specifically
sort of liberal regime credentials right
the ivy league school and harvard
medical and this so why is he doing is
he doing it because he believes these
things are really markers of of one's
greatness and virtue no
republicans especially desantis usually
kind of play down all that stuff you
know yeah okay i went to whatever i went
to harvard i went to yale but you know
what does that mean these days there are
a bunch of crazy degenerates who don't
know anything will go to those places
the reason he's doing it you can you can
sense it you can i'm getting giddy i'm
getting butterflies just listening to
desantis make this introduction is
because you know
if he's going to open up with this big
defensive look he's got all the smart
credentials
you know this guy is going to be an
absolute
wrecking ball for the conservatives
and he does not disappoint i talked to
the governor and there are a few things
that we're going to keep in mind as we
approach public health here
in the state of florida florida will
completely reject fear as a way of
making policies in public health so
we're done with fear we're going to be
very explicit about the differences
between the science
and our opinions and this idea that you
know people don't get to make their own
decisions you know on issues of health
related to their own their own personal
health
is um is is is
is wrong and it's um and it's not
something that we're going to be about
there are good reasons to reject
lockdowns after lockdowns overall
mortality increase lockdowns are bad we
need to respect human rights that you
know people do have autonomy over their
lives and it's not okay to it's not even
not okay but it's not it's not virtuous
and it's not right to just sort of take
away those rights from individuals
vaccines are up to the person there's
nothing special about them compared to
any other preventive preventive
measure the state should be promoting
good health and vaccination isn't the
only path to that it's been treated
almost like a religion
yes
yes oh man i know that everyone's
talking about desantis for president
let's run that guy for president let's
run them both let's run both on a ticket
oh my gosh i love this guy i knew i knew
it when desantis was saying and look
before he starts talking just he went to
harvard
he went to your school libs he went to
harvard medical actually which is even
more impressive yeah
yeah he was what was it ucla or
something yeah that's another one of
your schools
all right buddy what do you have to say
masks are stupid vaccines are stupid the
vaccine mandates and the mask mandates
are especially stupid people have
control over their lives don't live in
fear focus on virtue hahaha that's what
he said
love it
i totally love it
it's
this is what you need to hear because by
the way when he's saying he's not quite
saying vaccines are stupid but he's
making a very important point he's
saying yeah vaccines are fine but
they're just one
measure they're just one measure
there are other met what about
therapeutics think about this with aids
for
for years and years decades and decades
under the guidance of dr fauci actually
the federal government tried to find a
vaccine for aids it never happened they
never found one but people with aids can
live a very long time now because of
therapeutics because of drugs why they
did the same sort of focus here in
coronavirus put all the money behind a
vaccine don't focus on any treatments if
anyone does take a treatment say that
they're eating horse paste or something
and this guy comes out
an appointed figure and says yeah the
lockdowns actually were bad the insane
focus on these little measures are bad
we're not going to do it we're not going
to live in fear
i know that youtube or all these other
places are gonna try to take me down for
that i'm quoting the science i'm just
playing you the science
and a man who says there's a big
difference between science
and our political opinions
on monday 500
women
including u.s soccer player megan repino
and lots of other professional athletes
called on the supreme court
to strike down the mississippi law that
prevents babies from being killed by
abortion
why is this news why do i care what
megan repino thinks about anything i
certainly don't why does the supreme
court care what megan rapino thinks
about anything
they certainly should not
the reason they're filing this brief for
the court is they just want to gin up
public opinion to pressure the court to
strike down a law that protects all
these babies from being killed this is a
supreme court case that very possibly
could overturn roe versus wade and
planned parenthood v casey which was the
case that affirmed roe versus wade
the the only reason this story
struck me in any way is newsworthy as i
thought it was kind of weird
that megan repino would be so concerned
about abortion
because last time i checked megan repino
was very famously uh
not interested in men
i don't i don't think there is any
occasion on which megan repino would
require
or desire
or have any relationship to
an abortion
nobody ever requires an abortion
least of all megan repino
so why why is one of the most famous
lesbians in the country so jinned up
about abortion an issue that has
absolutely nothing to do with her
i think it gets to
this this issue
that is really at the heart of
leftism but really at the heart of
liberalism and actually kind of at the
heart of some libertarianism too
this radical individualism
that that what
the left and the right have been doing
since the 1960s since the kind of
cultural revolutions of the 1960s
but you saw the seeds of this going back
hundreds and hundreds of years
is prioritizing the individual
above all else that that the
the
defining feature of all of modernity is
emancipation
emancipation from
kings
emancipation from
your home country emancipation from
social mores emancipation from the
family emancipation even from yourself
emancipation even if i'm a man i want to
be emancipated and seem like a woman
that i can now do that emancipation from
the natural bonds of motherhood
if i don't want to be a mother but i am
i'll just kill the baby and that's
that's part of the emancipation that's
my right
it all goes in together
i know some people seem to think that uh
you know feminism is going to undermine
transgenderism or or the lgbt movement
but it's all kind of the same it all
gets down to this
fundamental emancipation from from any
sort of natural bounds any sort of
natural distinctions
which is why
i was
really shocked i shouldn't have been
shocked though to see that this is
infecting every element of society
including even
catholics you know the catholics should
be the holdout here because the
catholics
just never really went along with all
that kind of modern individualism
liberalism they just kind of rejected
that they're pretty pretty old school
about these things and yet i saw this
article the other day a postmodern
catholic divinity student let's go for a
moment of grace and this this student
was describing how he he wanted to visit
a hindu temple so he wanted to go visit
a hindu temple ceremony for an
assignment
in his graduate seminar
and so
he he didn't end up doing that because
he was afraid of coronavirus so he just
did it online which makes the story even
funnier but he's there and he's sort of
digitally participating in this
and then he's watching it and kind of
taking notes but he said no i shouldn't
just watch it i should participate in
this
as well i'm doing this wrong i'm
observing
but i'm not part of the puja i'm not i'm
not distancing myself so he paused the
video takes a deep breath exhales then
he stares into ganesha's eyes and
something wonderful happens i'm
entranced mesmerized ganesha's eyes seem
to stare back as the chanting wafts over
me i slide into its rhythm one voice
just breathing just being the chanting
the distance of bells as the puja ends
i'm still staring into ganesha's eyes
the eyes of ganesha are all that exists
all that there is in my world
what happened a moment of grace
even even though i was in a
non-christian setting
i i must find a deeper answer that goes
beyond imposing christian theology and
values on a hindu puja
in other words
he's uh
worshiping pagan idols
to own
the traditionalists to own the
conservatives to own the people who
don't believe you should emancipate
yourself from everything
you you actually hear this argument
sometimes you'll hear people say look
i'm going to violate some
well-established tenet of christianity
whether it's on i don't know theology of
the body you know sex issues or whether
it's on liturgical issues or whether
it's on
you know christological issues or
whatever i'm going to violate some some
important doctrine of christianity
because that's really the most christian
thing i could do
the most christian thing i could do
would be to worship pagan idols because
it's so open-minded it's not
it's not and there's nothing there's
nothing new about this that people think
this is some new revelation no
worshiping pagan idols is the default
for humanity okay that's what everyone
did for all of human history everywhere
until
the ancient israelites
and then until
that idea of worshiping one god finds
its culmination it's fulfillment in
christianity
and now we're going back to that there
is nothing new under the sun folks i
assure you
the worship of pagan idols
is is not new
this actually there was an another
article good article on unheard how
satanism conquered america just
observing that satanism is just
untrammeled individualism do whatever
you want ye shall be his gods that's
what the serpent says to eve in the
garden of eden that's how john milton
kind of views satanism too and so when
we just do whatever we want at any given
time that there is really no distinction
here and that's why these sorts of
things have uh darker
symbols associated with them there's
nothing new under the sun we look at our
new government oh we have the
enlightenment
brilliant genius scientific
rule of the experts it's just oligarchy
it's there have been a lot of
oligarchies in history and we're
descending into one now as well
and you know i mentioned angelo
cotavilla earlier we've just lost one of
the great the one of the great minds on
this issue so uh let's not
forget about it let's not memory hold it
let's recognize let's see this moment
clearly for what it is let's not get
lost in ganesha's eyes or whatever let's
not get lost in dr fauci's eyes either
let's see this for what it is let's
decide what kind of society we want to
live and what government we want to live
under and let's exercise our political
authority such as we still have it to do
so i'm michael moses the michael knowles
shall see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show